Autobahnen die strom produzieren oder intelligente straßen die schäden oder glatteis direkt an die entsprechenden
stellen kommunizieren oder sich sogar selbst reparieren genau solche ideen in sachen straßenbau werden jetzt auf einem neuartigen
Testgelände in deutschland auf herz und nieren geprüft wie realistisch diese pläne sind und wie wohl die zukunft unserer
verkehrsstraßen aussieht jetzt in klicks und science fiction herzlich willkommen
Selbst wenn bauingenieure heutzutage eine richtig coole
Innovative idee haben dauert es rund 30 jahre um eine neue straßenbau technik auch tatsächlich auf die straße
zu bringen und nach solch einer langen zeitspanne
Ist die technik alles nur nicht mehr innovativ sie ist schon ein alter hut vor allem auch bei der gegebenen veralteten
infrastruktur und der zunehmenden verkehrsdichte
Sind die neuen verfahren dann auch gerne schon mal überholen nicht. Zu vergessen auch zunehmende extreme
wetterlagen wie uns in zukunft vielleicht über mehrere wochen hitze hitze von rund 40 grad bescheren werden die bundesanstalt für straßenwesen
Bast hat jetzt ein riesiges forschungs areal in köln realisiert
Wo neue entwicklungen in sachen verkehr der zukunft getestet werden hier forscht deutschland also an den
Autobahnen und strafen der zukunft es geht um neue baustoffe bauverfahren und auch bauweisen der traum eines jeden
verkehrsplaners heißt nur abbas und steht für
demonstrations-
Untersuchungs und referenz areal der passt jetzt gerade wurde es
Im autobahnkreuz köln-ost auf einem nicht gebrauchten autobahnstück eröffnet
da hatte man in den 70er jahren ein wenig zu
aufwändig gebaut seit kurzem laufen jetzt erste tests 2400 meter straße wurden hier unter freiem himmel angelegt und zwar aus
unterschiedlichen materialien also strecken mit verschiedenen texturen und
Unterschiedlicher griffigkeit wie die bast auf ihrer webseite schreibt dazu kommen flächen zu wenden und parken insgesamt ist das testgelände rund
25.000 quadratmeter groß seit juni
2015 wurde es gebaut die kosten lagen bei rund 13 millionen euro dafür soll es aber auch
30 jahre lang genutzt werden es geht um wirklich
spektakuläre ideen intelligente brücken die mit sensoren ausgestattet sind oder beispielsweise straßen innerhalb kürzester zeit mit hilfe von
betonfertigteilen gebaut werden können sowie ein ikea regal eine idee die hier außerdem getestet wird sind selbstheilende straßen das wundermittel
Magnetische partikel die im bau gemisch enthalten sind funktionieren soll das ganze dann wie ein
induktionskochfeld
das magnetische töpfer hits der beteiligte ingenieur sebastian backer zieht den vergleich
Auf dem testgelände ist die straße der topf und das induktions gerät das eingesetzt wird die
der platte denn induktions energie erwärmt die magnetischen teilchen schlagartig wir tun das mit asphalt
Als bindemittel eingesetzt wird dehnt sich aus und auch seine zähigkeit
verändert sich die folge kleine risse schließen sich damit kann dann kein wasser eindringen das dann
Im winter gefriert und die straße weiter zerstört dafür benötigt wird dann nur eine
induktions maschine mit der man die straße abfährt und sie dadurch sehr viel langlebiger macht der fachbegriff dafür heißt
hier rot vorbei also die zeiten in denen die straßen dicht sind weil alle 500 meter eine neue baustelle den verkehr blockiert zudem
Soll damit geld gespart werden und auch eine weitere idee die auf dem kölner testgelände getestet wird könnte den verkehr
Revolutionieren straßen die strom produzieren das fett erhitzt sich ja. Im sommer stark schade
Um die energie die doch eigentlich genutzt werden könnte und genau das ist der plan ein rohrnetz
In der oberen schicht der straße würde mit hilfe von kühlflüssigkeit
energie abführen die könnte dann in einem zweiten schritt in strom umgewandelt werden der absolut geniale
Nebeneffekt bei diesem prozess sinkt die temperatur der straßen es entstehen deutlich weniger spuren gerade auf autobahnen sind ja auch ziemlich
gefährlich und das würde baustellen und staus enorm verringern die so entstandenen straßen müssen
Im winter und bei frost übrigens auch nicht mehr mit salz gestreut werden denn durch die rohre könnte dann warmes wasser laufen
Dass die straßen so von unten wärmt es könnte erdwärme dafür genutzt werden
So dass dafür auch nur wenig energie verbraucht werden würde und das kölner testgelände ist nicht das einzige
forschungsfeld zum verkehr und den straßen der zukunft wissenschaftlerinnen und wissenschaftler aus münchen tüfteln an der lebenden straße
spezielle bakterien sollen
Im straße material angesiedelt werden die idee dahinter die mikroben werden quasi durch das wasser das durch entstehende
Schadstellen in die fahrbahn laufen würde aktiviert ihre ausscheidungs produkte könnten dann dabei
helfen den beton wieder zu verkleben also abzudichten auch mit diesem verfahren
Würden dann größere straßenschäden durch gefrierendes wasser in der zukunft schon. Im vorfeld verhindert werden und an
intelligenten straßen wird hier gearbeitet die die idee dahinter
sensor warnsysteme dem asphalt integriert sind würden schäden oder glatt heißt direkt
entsprechende techniker und wartungs teams weiter geben diese infos würden auch selbst fahrende autos mit
wichtigen infos versorgen und sollen letztendlich zu weniger staus und unfällen verhelfen fest steht jedenfalls
Die straßen der zukunft werden mehr sein als langweilige graue
asphaltpisten
zumindest innen drin oder unten drunter
Wenn es mehr infos zu den forschungsergebnissen vom dura bast und allen anderen forschern und forscherinnen in diesem bereich gibt erfahrt ihr natürlich hier
Wenn er kein video dazu verpassen und dann wird mir hier ein aber aufs auge und vergesst nicht den
Auf die glocke denn nur dann erfahrt ihr nur wirklich dann wenn ein neues video online gehen und hier geht es weiter mit tempo
200 unterirdisch durch die stadt einer innovativen lösung von wem wohl ihnen muss einfach. Draufklicken wenn es euch interessiert und ansonsten bis dann